ein arbeitsloser herzlich willkommen
hier heute zu einem neuen video auf
meinem kanal jahr und wahrscheinlich vor
einigen tagen das video auf einem kanal
gesehen namens meine nummer ist
öffentlich jedem video ging es darum
dass ich mir eine neue sim-karte
gestellt habe die habe ich in ein
zweites handy hier von mir gewachsen und
habe in watts 16 gruppen erstellt für
insgesamt 1500 leute von euch so dass
wir zusammen eine gruppe habe in den
gruppen einstellungen habe ich
allerdings eingestellt dass nur ich dort
schreiben kann also ich kann das bild
bearbeiten und ich kann dort bilder
einsenden sprachnachrichten irgendwelche
updates zu videos manier mal in
fantreffen vielleicht machen oder
bezüglich klamotten irgendwelche updates
nur ich konnte unter anderem die gruppen
beschreibung bearbeiten das gruppenbild
ich hätte da ich habe das handy vor
allem auch die ganze zeit im flugmodus
aber mit wlan genutzt so dass ich quasi
ja nicht angerufen werden konnte beim
mobilfunkbetreiber was ich allerdings
vergessen habe meinen ganzen
sicherheitsvorkehrungen sage ich mal
waren prozent wlan kreuz
erst ein anruf für die nicht über den
mobilfunkbetreiber gehen also die ich
mit einem flug modus nicht stoppen kann
sondern die gehen über wlan und mein
handy ist nach drei sekunden nachdem das
video online war abgestürzt und ich habe
es nicht mehr an gekriegt ich habe sich
das handy komplett entladen lassen habe
es jetzt neu aufgeladen und direkt im
flugmodus gestartet ich will eigentlich
auch gar nicht raus aus dem flug modus
also ich bin gerade im kompletten
flugmodus nicht mit wlan oder irgendwie
so war es deshalb wenn ich jetzt gleich
wieder wieder einstelle werde ich die
ganze zeit wieder angerufen mein handy
hat
ich glaube es hat vier 10.000 oder
15.000 nachrichten ich bin jetzt im
flugmodus einfach mal in what's up
gegangen ich halte euch mal die nummern
hinzu ich weiß nicht nur das wesen
irgendwie so an die 14.000 nachrichten
und das war vor drei tagen
wenn ich gleich aus den flugmodus kraus
gesteht dann wahrscheinlich mit 20.000
ich habe diese mail an anrufe halt
einfach wirklich nicht bedacht ich sagte
mir okay ich hab alles richtig
eingestellt hier mich vor lange
informiert das irgendwie das ich mit
euch rein
es geht nicht ich wollte die ganze zeit
anrufe noch nichts in einer dieser
usergruppen beschreiben können es tut
mir unendlich leid wir haben auch so
viele leute die kommentare geschrieben
heyo k was meine neue gruppen die die
sind alle voll gewesen nach 34 sekunden
es tut mir leid ich konnte also ich
konnte bisher nichts schreiben in diesen
gruppen die ganze aktion völlig okay
heute jedoch ihr seht bereits intel
eingeblendet ich will euch in diesem
video gar nicht nur ein update geben
bezüglich dieser woche fraktion von weg
hey leute es klappt doch nicht nee ich
habe mir gedacht dass wenn das jetzt
schon alles für die katz war diese ganze
gruppen dass sich wenigstens bei einigen
anrufen von euch ran gehen kann und euch
einfach mal überraschen kann am telefon
das heißt sie jetzt hier oben runter
clique auch wlan aktivieren und dann
warten wir mal bis der erste anruf
reinkommen kaiser schon eine stunde
später das handy hört doch auf das handy
ist tatsächlich direkt abgestürzt sein
anruf angenommen habe weil ganz whatsapp
pinky wieder 10.000 neue nachrichten
geladen hat jetzt funktioniert
allerdings und ich werde dir angerufen
werden drangeben ehrlich nicht ja also
es kommt gerade voll viele anrufe die
ganze zeit rein deswegen ich weiß nicht
ob es nicht richtig verstehen kannst
okay das alter möchte irgend jemanden
grüßen meinem video hat den namen also
das war die person nummer eins das heißt
ich würde sagen gewahrt sind jetzt bis
die nächste person an ruft hallo
direkt auflegen was geht es denn jetzt
ja wir geht auch sehr gutes klasse mein
handy ist gerade eine stunde lang
abgeschmiert aber jetzt telefonieren wir
gerade ehrlich warum ich bin auch ganz
normaler sommer spaß die 63 ist das ein
auto das ist ja lustig die meisten sind
so hätte nie gedacht dass du dran gehen
da ist direkt der liste hallo alter das
hat mir bisher jeder gesagt mit dem ich
telefoniert habe oh mein gott noch
grüßen kreis okay natürlich schöne grüße
einen gottesstaat lernen muss
da hier dankeschön jeder der wirklich
bisher meine so hey das ist unerwartet
voll krass dass du einfach rangegangen
bisher klar
nächster anruf was geht
wir stehen etwas was dir mir geht es
sehr sehr gut du bist tatsächlich die
erste die mich direkt fragen wie es mir
geht nicht sehr gut sagte wie geht's
euch danke ich mag euch auch die wahl
tatsächlich sehr sehr interessant also
direkt rom geschrieben dass man
tatsächlich die erdachten wenn man hier
an
wie geht hier ja doch was machst du
gerade
[Musik]
im ernst ich habe hunger gerade ich
versuche seit zwei stunden dieses video
aufzunehmen weil die ganze zeit mein
handy abschmiert wenn ich bei anrufen
rangehe und trotzdem alles und lava
dann kommst du ja das ist doch noch
pizza nebenbei ja gerade möchte jemanden
in meinem video grüßen
okay ganz liebe grüße antalya und sarah
von der lieben markt dar
[Musik]
hallo
diese anrufe genießt du darfst noch drei
worte mein video sagen das waren schon
zwei wörter der anruf ist gerade
irgendwie weg gegangen
aber da kommt direkt der nächste hallo
wie geht's dir gut geht mir danke der
nachfrage wie jetzt hier richtig geil
geht's dir wie alt seid ihr 10 und hat
schon handy mit kras hast dir selbst
gekauft oder geschenkt bekommen ein
handy
[Musik]
hab so okay okay jetzt jetzt verstehe
ich alles spielt ihr fortnight bist du
so gut wie ich also ich bin definitiv ja
ich bin ich bin sehr gut in dem spiel
das weiß ich danke leute ich würde sagen
wir machen jetzt auch einen letzten
anruf das ist echt mega lustig einfach
mit euch zu psycho von ihr und die
reaktion sage ich mal abzuwarten dass
der nächste hallo hier ist luca wg ist
wie stets wie heißt du was machst du wie
groß bist du alt bist du wenn ich fragen
darf 13 okay was ist deine
lieblingsfarbe keine ahnung hat
eigentlich keine hast keine
lieblingsfarbe hast du lieblingstier ja
und und ok grad ich liebe auch hunde
habe den hund ja ehrlich was für ein
nein der sogar richtig süß oder
ja ich will auch seitdem viermal am tag
habt ihr eure hundefutter in hannover
abgestellter frau und was hat er für ein
halsband der rund 110 möglichst noch
jemanden grüßen in meinem video ja
freunde ich dachte mir einfach hey bevor
ich euch jetzt einfach sagen hey das hat
nicht geklappt der ortsgruppe mein handy
ist da die ganzen abgeschmiert dachte
ich mir gehe ich einfach bei einem paar
anrufen ran
weswegen das händigt die ganze zeit
abgeschmiert ist wenn euch dieses video
heute gefallen hat das gerne mal einen
daumen hoch da ist weiß eigentlich ohne
großen sinn oder ohne große challenge
oder irgendwas in dem heutigen video
sondern einfach nur mit euch reden und
ein paar leuten von euch sage ich mal
den tag ein bisschen verschönern dadurch
dass ich vollidiot ans handy kann mal
wieso kann euch das eigentlich freuen
wenn euch das video gefallen das gerne
mal einen leiter schreibt mir gerne und
in die kommentare ob ich eventuell noch
mal probieren sollen mit telegramm eine
gruppe zu machen
das haben wir nämlich viele leute gesagt
dass es mit telegramm funktionieren
sollte wenn ihr damit erfahrungen habt
könnt ihr gerne in die kommentare
und jetzt kommt das auto
[Musik]
die